of course Levon aronia welcome to the
show
tell us a little bit about your approach
countering the Sicilian we've seen you
use this in Rapid but how well did it
work in uh classical chess
I just thought that you know just to
play just to see how it goes you know
just to
come up with some ideas so this was my
uh approach today because linear is a
great theoretical player I mean he I
mean he's a great player but he also
knows the theory very well so I thought
no I just should just play regular chess
did you feel you know him better as a
player now that you were teammates in
the recent Olympiad
um I generally know him quite well not
as a just as a teammate but also as a
dear friend
someone host company I
enjoy very much whose family I consider
to be one of the closest families to my
family excellent so take us a little bit
through some of the key moments you
think that perhaps were uh interesting
here in this game
yeah I thought this rugby one is a is an
interesting try you know just to get
some
kind of stub black from immediately
equalizing with D5 and so B5 I thought
Knight B8 is a good move here B5 instead
of retreating uh yeah yeah because
Knight A5 I think is strategically risky
with the night so offside yeah and 95 is
also kind of strategically risky because
they just take and play Knight Knight G3
you know rookie one Knight F1 Knight E3
once I established this dominance over
the C4 square and even when the knights
are off uh the bishop is is not a
happy bunny not so much right this one
in B7 yeah yeah so he countered this
properly by playing the Knight to bieda
a counter developing move and it seemed
that after the movie A6 he was pretty
much equal yeah I think he played quite
well here and then I think uh I took a
bit of a risk when I went for all of
this I thought C3 you know it's it's a
it's a very double-edged position if
black goes you know for night of Faith
with the idea Knight C7 you know trying
to take the pawn 98.97 yeah because 98
D4 let's say yes 97
it gets extremely sharp I mean you might
just lose the pawn right yeah yeah
because you can close it with C4 but
then I get my play on the king side so I
was kind of getting excited and then 95
I think was a strong move like if I just
shutting this down right yeah because
now uh I will have to put the pawn on C4
I think right I try to by Quincy too but
then yeah what I did I thought made
sense you mean you're trying not to put
the Pono C4
but somehow I can't work this uh I can't
make this nice E4 work on move 34.
uh 24 sorry 24 here 94. somehow Rook B5
and it seems that everything is covered
for him right now it seemed to me that I
might have this good play with Rook A1
Knight C4 Bishop C4 okay five
takes takes and no all those weaknesses
but the Rook protects
DFI phone the bishop protects the C5 and
he just comes out so it's it's an equal
position all right so at the end you
decided to agree to a draw here it did
seem about equal too close for the
position
yeah I mean if I exchange the Rooks then
how I'm going to win and if I don't
exchange the Rooks you will always have
a counter play so it's tiny bit better
for white because I can
I mean I have the chances to play on but
uh I didn't see a way I can progress in
this position yeah it's difficult for
sure we thought this was a very safe
construction even in buckhouse
absolutely the one I have to ask you
what was your thought process and
reaction seeing the world champion
Magnus Carlos and not show up for
today's game
um I don't know maybe his uh
sick I don't know it happens he has
withdrawn from the tournament we are
told it is not health related but we
haven't been given a full explanation
just yet we'll definitely update it a
little bit of buzzing going around for
the players afterwards
I think uh it's quite often happens when
young players play very well there is
all this Acquisitions towards them I've
I'm in all of my colleagues are pretty
much paranoid and quite often I was the
one telling them come on guys I mean I
know myself I'm an idiot and I'm a good
player I mean I I always think that
young players can play very well I mean
there is no reason for them not to play
well so I never have this kind of
feeling I mean oh my opponent is uh you
know he's over performing because
and at the same time I mean if the young
players are not playing very well or not
occasionally beating us then what can we
learn from them you know and it also
shows that we haven't taught them
anything
[Laughter]
and I personally I've played against
Magnus when he was very young and I've
learned for him a great deal of course
one of the more traditional Powerhouse
matches that we've had in the last
decade a decade and a half and therefore
I mean if I was sitting there and
thinking that he's you know there's
something suspicious about how strong he
plays
it I I don't think it would be very
beneficial for me I could never learn
from him I would always think that now
his there is something wrong with his
player yeah yeah did you feel that
you've learned from your encounters here
at the singfield cup absolutely
yesterday I've learned a great deal I
think I
underestimated the attack of my opponent
and uh
I really underestimated this movie three
in my preparation and I think he played
very very well so as upsetting it is you
know
it's an opportunity to learn and improve
you know
there is that that's what motivates me
in life
you can always learn about Chess and
about life from Leon thank you for
joining us here and well good luck in
the rest of your games thank you thank
you Lavon for sure and at our we
strongly Echo that it's uh when Lavon is
playing well